I wish that that we could have done like
a you know a better job of really
getting people to see the importance of
Ubi by doing a lot of other things like
I really want to see like say a coal
miner's pilot you know somewhere in like
West Virginia or something like that
it's like if if you have different types
of populations in uh in different more
rural areas like I I think it would be
compelling to different groups and we
need the data from my perspective like
we have the data we know that it works
it's just that I want people to see the
importance of it themselves and see
themselves in these pilot participants
that's where kind of what we're what
we're not doing by focusing on these
like a lower smaller subset of
demographics it's it's not reaching
everybody that it could
foreign
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome back to the
podcast my Guru and all things Ubi the
man who came up with not left not right
but forward which he's wearing if you
could see him advisor to humanity
forward Scott santins welcome Scott hey
Andrew good to see you yeah we were just
joking and laughing how you were the one
who said to me ubi's not left or right
it's forward in
2017 or 2018 and I said ooh that's
genius that
a couple years later I I use that as a
closing in one of the debates and then
now it's on a t-shirt or actually
multiple t-shirts as I think about it
um but but you yeah got into Ubi before
it was a thing uh and I'm sincere in
saying that I just learned most all of
it uh from you
um you and I first met in New Orleans
and was that 2017 that wasn't where we
first met I don't think I think we met
for the first time in California at the
cash conference yeah before that even
like one of the smaller conferences
before the cash conference yeah so I
learned a lot from you and then we
fought it out all the way through Iowa
New Hampshire I vividly remember hanging
out with you in Iowa it in January
2020. yeah before everything turned
upside down before everything turned
upside down yeah and and then it's been
a bit of a you know like a buzz saw uh
you know shut down for covid uh and a
bunch of other things
um but I I wanted to talk to you about
the latest and greatest with Ubi and uh
and I I'm going to pre-seed our
discussion talking about my Outlook
um for Ubi and on Ubi so I run for
president on it uh get it the you know I
like to think that we helped you me and
a lot of other people and the Yang gang
helped mainstream it where before that
presidential campaign it wasn't really a
thing and then it became a thing we had
some version of it during covid with the
relief checks and
um the enhanced child tax credit
it gets mistakenly blamed for inflation
later which is uh you know very
upsetting and frustrating and troubling
yeah because everyone's like oh I mean
you send checks out and then prices go
up it's like well if you do the math you
realize that the checks were a very very
small component of the five trillion
that went went out I try and explain to
people it's like look five trillion
dollars is 15 16 000 ahead like do you
remember sending out fifteen sixteen
thousand ahead you know he's about like
you know maybe like one or two grand
ahead so what the hell happened to the
other you know 13 14 Grand and uh try
and paint a picture it's like well I
went into the financial system I went to
big corporates and went to States I went
to cities went to all the stuff so they
flood the Zone with money
uh the efficacy of cash relief actually
gets borne out during this period
particularly through the enhanced child
tax credit you and I team up to start
Humanity forward in 2020 to try and
Advance these policies that you are I'm
right that you're still officially an
advisor right yeah and you moved from
New Orleans to Washington DC yeah good
fun so uh so you and I helped kick off
Humanity forward that's still trying to
advance uh these policies in a
non-partisan bipartisan way uh with a
Focus right now on trying to revive the
child tax credit and I gotta say I was
so sad and frustrated when the child tax
credit was discontinued yeah yeah you
know the beginning of last year I'm
still pushing for these policies I
concluded in you I think you agree
because you're one of the people that
also put me onto this since I tend to
take your lead on a lot of things that
that the two-party system actually is
part of the issue because it locks
things up and makes it so it's very hard
to advance meaningful policies that
stand the test of time and I I became
convinced that
reforming our Democratic structures
actually precede solving very meaningful
problems uh so I'm still marching after
the same stuff but uh you know like I
feel like there are some things we have
to resolve in order to to get these
things done so that's my very lengthy
Preamble most of which is old news to
you so during that time you have been
tirelessly advocating for a Ubi day in
day out like what is the latest on your
front I would also just say too just as
a little bit more uh Preamble and maybe
we'll get into a little bit more later
too because I think it is important
about any discussion about Ubi when it
comes to inflation and like people
blaming the stimulus checks and and
everything that we did on the inflation
that we're seeing like uh it's just kind
of crazy to me too that that we were in
a pandemic like a once in a century
pandemic like just happened and over a
million Americans are dead now because
of it and it's just crazy to me to think
that we just like look at that kind of
like extreme circumstance with like
heavily constrained Global supply lines
and just all sorts of things happening
and then look at the cash as being like
something we did wrong when like
absolutely we needed to do that and then
the other side of this too is that we
people don't see what we didn't see
because we did the cash and so the the
even the debate then too at the time was
if we don't do this if we don't get
money to people
then we can actually could potentially
lose you know over 10 trillion dollars
like the GDP uh would have been
depressed we would have been would have
taken a lot longer to get back to the
where we are now like would have been
worse in the Great Recession like it's
it's incredible that we were able to to
do what we did and I think it's
absolutely smart what we did but then we
actually ignore like what we you know
we're not seeing like we're not in
another like Second Great Depression
because of what we did but people are
complaining about inflation not that
there's something you know sure
inflation is is something that that
impacts everybody but really it could
have been so much worse than than what
we saw so you just want to get like that
out of the way too but uh yeah part of
this
um that I that I observed is sure enough
because the pandemic Ubi uh started to
be talked about in a different way and
people started to see this as something
that was important that we actually
should have had before the pandemic
happened how how positively that would
have impacted everything to actually
have the floor underneath people
um you know we saw what happened when
people suddenly had to go through the
unemployment insurance systems state by
state and how some states were better
than others and we saw like massive Food
Bank lines and yet the grocery stores
had food like we could have it could
have been so much better if we had a Ubi
so I think people kind of felt that and
and see that now for themselves then we
come out of this and people start
complaining about there's a labor
shortage that nobody wants to work
anymore and they're blaming us and the
stimulus they're blaming it on
unemployment and everything
but really it's just kind of a kind of
amazing that we actually were able to
get where we are now as far as getting
the labor participation rate back up but
at the time as it's going back up people
are looking at a labor shortage and
they're just coming up all kinds of
stuff and then at that point automation
became like a joke like I thought it was
crazy how
um like you were even like the butt of
jokes of of being like Oh like Andrew
Yang said that you know everyone would
be out of a job and yet we can't find
anyone to work
so um like that was laughable and so a
lot of automation became like this joke
and then all of a sudden I feel that all
changed last November uh when when chat
GPT launched like that was a total Game
Changer in the entire conversation where
suddenly people were like oh my gosh
this uh this is serious like AI can do
some magical things and so suddenly
we're in this world
where AI is just like
it's right there it's like it's
happening as we see it it's happening in
real time in a way that you know people
we're making fun of even just you know a
year ago and one of those things I find
frustrating Scott is like people like
what do you mean automation like people
who can't find people to work and it's
like well you know those two things
actually can happen at the same time
like you know companies can be investing
good jillions of dollars and automating
uh various roles and you have a hard
time getting people to show up for a job
extra job why particularly if those jobs
are frankly
punitive or undercompensated or whatever
the heck the the situation is so
um I agree with you that the
conversation definitely changed when
chat GPT came online everyone was like
wait a minute uh this thing can do what
I do you know this thing these things
scores an 88 percentile on the bar exam
it's like better than you know most
attorneys probably manage so for me the
trend has just been ongoing the whole
time I mean even during covid when
people were sent home I I saw one survey
that said that almost half of companies
said they were investing more in
Automation and by the way if you're
working remotely you are one step easier
to automate you know it's like if you're
essentially setting your work in and to
your point it's just going to get
stronger and faster I saw a tweet you
put out saying hey I thought that maybe
we could get Ubi up before AI came and
got us all but now it's too late and I I
did not disagree with your estimation I
do think it's changed the conversation I
would love to hear like some more of
what what you've been seeing on that
front
um so November happens Chachi BT comes
online it gets better in March and then
now is everyone saying like huh maybe we
should revisit Ubi like what's the tenor
so it like for for years now I I've made
a point of just regularly kind of
tracking what people are saying about
base income on Twitter and yeah there
was like you know during the pandemic it
was pandemic stuff and then there was a
kind of like a dead zone where it kind
of dropped off with inflation rising and
automation not being something I cared
about chat GPD comes out and now it I
would say since then there's just uh
like a growing conversation uh just all
sorts of people on on Twitter like I
know that I didn't notice them before
because I also make a point of trying to
follow anyone who's like speaking
favorably about basic income
um so I kind of like can keep track of
oh this is a person is new or not and
talking about it that's one reason we
love you Scott catalog
all things Ubi related yeah and so
recently I've just there's so many new
people that people I hadn't already been
following speaking favorable the basic
income and a lot of this is just through
the automation argument like it'll be in
response to someone talking about
automation something talking about chat
CPT or or mid-journey or you know some
other AI tool that's out there
and people will be like oh this is you
know this is crazy uh I don't know
what's gonna happen and then there's
just you know so many often so many
times there's someone in the reply
saying we're going to need to do
Universal basic income and so it's
really just part and parcel of this
conversation uh in a way that it wasn't
prior to the pandemic so you know I had
got into the to Ubi even originally
through the automation argument back in
2013 and that was that kind of kicked
off this kind of like new wave of
interest in in basic income
um but even then like people were
talking about automation
but they weren't talking about basic
income I was trying to inject that into
the conversation well done and you wrote
a book about it tried to eject out of
the conversation so like here we are
both trying to get people to connect
automation with basic income and now
it's on like autopilot now like people
who are talking about Automation and
talking about what's going on
the Ubi is part of the conversation
foreign
you guys already know all about
expressvpn I've talked before about why
they are the go-to service for
protecting your online activity big Tech
should not be snooping on us and
profiting from what we do in our private
time expressvpn can also help access
content including thousands of Netflix
shows that might be available in another
Market you just beam in encrypted
surreptitiously and you can be a UK user
and all of a sudden all that fun BBC
content can be yours I could go on and
on about expressvpn it's a VPN that I
trust and I'm not surprised that CNET
wired and others have rated it number
one visit expressvpn.com yang right now
and get three extra months of their
service for free that's exp r e s s
vpn.com Yang
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
[Music]
so now people are into okay we're
definitely going to automate away a
significant number of jobs and then they
also think well we're going to need Ubi
uh so
what what should we do next uh on I had
a conversation with a member of Congress
yesterday and she was favorable on uh
Ubi and uh the child tax credit and some
other things and one of the issues that
we discussed was that Mayors for a
guaranteed income organization got
started in 2020.
um and I want to say the vast majority
of the Mayors and Mayors for a
guaranteed income are Democrats maybe
all of them actually uh not just
Democrats but also uh Democrats of color
uh often black it's thrilling that there
are so many basic income pilots and
trials being rolled out uh around the
country yeah so a couple of things along
those lines first yeah I would I would
say that uh like it was a great thing
that Mayors for guaranteeing income
formed and you know over a hundred
Mayors so far have have signed on to
this and I believe
um over I think 50 now are have either
been done already or are active or in
the planning stages that's great one
thing I feel that that I wish would have
been more part of this was
kind of contextualizing Ubi more through
these so like one way of I think it's
important to look at these Pilots is you
know people will look at this and go
well that's not Universal that's not
testing universality that's testing like
some specific demographic like so maybe
it's uh kids exiting foster care or
um you know pregnant mothers a very
worthy population yeah like there's
there's some there's some various
populations out there
um artists uh just so many others and if
you if you look at this and say okay if
there was a universal basic income then
all artists would get it and so how
would that impact artists so then if you
look at just a subset and look at you
know 2 000 artists then you're actually
able to see you know what would be the
impact of Ubi on that group and then so
hopefully all artists after seeing this
can see oh this is how much of a benefit
would have up to me and then you can
build up these constituencies which each
each of these Pilots That's How like I
wish they would have gone to really like
try to get all sorts of different
demographics and not to repeat the same
one in another place but really try to
to do different things all over
unfortunately
um that's not the what happened and some
cities are even just like say boosting
their earned income tax credit or
something like that where you know that
already exists it's nothing new it's
just like utilizing this excitement
um for basic income Pilots uh to just
like
Channel funds through existing
mechanisms and so uh on that like I'm
disappointed in that way about those
kinds of of things I wish that that we
could have done like um you know a
better job of really getting people to
see the importance of Ubi by doing a lot
of other things like I really want to
see like say a coal miner's pilot you
know somewhere in like West Virginia or
something like that it's like if you
have different types of populations in
uh in different more rural areas like I
I think it would be compelling to
different groups and we need the data
yeah I mean and I would say we need
those stories uh like from my
perspective like we have the data we
know that it works it's just that I want
people to see the importance of it
themselves and see themselves in these
pilot participants and
um I think I think that's where kind of
what we're what we're not doing is by
focusing on these like a lower or
smaller subset of democrat Graphics it's
it's not reaching everybody that it
could
um so that's one thing I on a more uh
also kind of a depressing pointer a
frustration point for me is uh this is
another result of the pandemic and
everything that we saw so as the
pandemic happens you see this this boost
in anti-vaccination uh and and
conspiracy groups and like even just
conspiracy theories in general kind of
like get a boost and they spread uh you
know in a way that you know I've never
seen before uh it's just kind of like I
think social media is especially
designed uh to amplify this kind of
stuff and so um as part of this there's
um I I think the the origin point of
this was the the freedom Convoy in
Canada
and uh when when uh the Prime Minister
Trudeau there in Canada uh responded to
the Convoy and how that they were there
in Ottawa and and just blocking
everything and preventing
um things were happening there and not
leaving then
um
he took actions there that just really
inflamed this whole community and as a
result of that
Ubi is now something that a lot of
people in this conspiracy theory world
now fear and they they see it as a tool
of control
you know they say that oh uh you know
it's it's the you know World economic
forum and Klaus Schwab wants to control
everything he's the the real world
leader and he wants to like trick you
into being under his control by having a
base income well what's funny man is if
if you send me money it probably makes
me free or not less free but go on
you know so a lot of the times they'll
say do you think like seniors on Social
Security are less free
um and of course not like seniors on
Social Security they're the ones who the
government responds to like they they're
the boys out there right right and so it
like the I think these they see basic
income and they say oh you're supported
by the government and therefore the
government can take it away from you and
and utilize that as a means of control
and even though that's exactly how
welfare Works let's you know that's
something that's controlled and
conditional but basic income is not that
it's Universal and unconditional but
they're kind of like afraid of this say
fake Ubi this like this Ubi that isn't
and
um and now they're saying like oh it's
going to be attached to cbdc's uh cbdc's
or weak programmable money so the
government will prevent you from buying
what you actually want to buy uh you
know they're getting rid of cash like
all these things in Ubi is right up in
there uh so it's like if if you talk to
somebody
who is a anti-world economic Forum uh
they're anti-
they're also anti 15-minute cities
they're anti-vaccine they're anti-bug
eating which they they think that like
the like Klaus Schwab and they lead to
the world want us to want to force us
all to eat bugs instead of hamburgers
like there's some really weird stuff out
there but Ubi is is part of it and
that's been really frustrating to see so
I wouldn't say that ubis become
polarized but I would say that there is
a constituency that's mostly on the
right
that believes in this stuff and
therefore has come to see ubis this like
evil thing and yeah that's that's that's
very frustrating me to to have seen that
be one of the outcomes of the pandemic
hey YouTube glad you're enjoying the
podcast if you really like it hit
subscribe and then YouTube will notify
you every time we have a bang-up new
guest thank you
when you talk about some of the like
these more negative sentiments I feel
like people have been in a bad mood a
funk uh mistrustful for oh approximately
two and a half years now something like
that and before
well you know yeah I mean there's been
this like giant plummeting in
institutional trust and capacities and
it's been I mean it's been like bizarre
uh I I felt it too at times if you had a
more functional system so we're talking
about automation as one one topic one of
the things that makes me incredibly
frustrated is that let's say that Chad
gbt does eat
a few million jobs in the next year uh
two years whatever the time frame is
how would we even know at this point you
know what I mean like like would there
be this media consensus saying yup that
happened you know like we used to have x
million office workers and now we don't
like this thing's real time for the
government to do something uh like that
entire set of uh steps that you might
imagine would happen in a more
functional system now even I don't
believe would happen you know you know
it's like I mean I'm continuously
looking at economic data trying to parse
it's like what is happening out there uh
and you you have the party and power
saying like things are great and then
the party out of power being like these
are terrible and folks are responding to
those arguments really based upon which
side they favor
um you know if you had let's say
non-partisan primaries and Ryan Choice
voting and then everyone had to like
actually deliver or lose their jobs as
opposed to now it's like you know I can
deliver I cannot deliver it doesn't
really matter as long as I try and keep
the 10 to 12 percent of the primary
voters happiest then you know the
problems don't really matter that like
the automation doesn't matter it's like
you know uh really the the question is
how our political system uh will respond
in real life uh and I I confess you know
like my optimism about that is lower
than it might have been
um back in 2018 or 2019 right no mine's
plummeted I'm so glad to hear you say
that I mean I'm not because it's super
upsetting but also I see you as
extraordinarily Lucid uh you know you're
like Lucid rational and practical things
that I imagine myself to be on good days
you know what I mean it's like okay how
are we going to get this done in
real life and yeah like you're you're
like looking at it I mean hell you even
moved to DC to help try and make this
happen and and and your faith in
these institutions being rational it
sounds like has gone the same direction
mine has yeah it's and it's not only the
like it's not only let's say the
American institutions I I think it's
even just an issue you know with with
just government itself so even if we had
like a highly reactive government I I
think that we're looking at a situation
where you know a Highly Effective
Government has to be highly effective in
trying to figure out just how far ahead
of the player to throw the football in
order to you know get the touchdown like
technology is is happening you know AI
is happening so quickly uh that you know
even even if you're in it and you're
like focused on it and um you can you
can still just be uh just taken aback by
how quickly it's happening uh yeah I
mean technologists are freaking out
about how fast yeah I think they're like
no way the the rate of paper publication
right now is is already up to 4 000
papers a month and this is growing at a
logarithmic scale it's just a straight
line going up a bit at a normal scale
it's just you know you're looking at the
hockey puck but even just like trying
the the process of like all right what
are all the things that are happening
where is the state of the art right now
and then suddenly something new happens
and then something new happens again
another new study and that's just one
person me trying to keep up on
everything so if if one person is having
a hard time how the heck do you like
actually get members of Congress to be
up to speed on this like even if they
had if each and this is like your
full-time staff member right like they
would each have to have one full-time AI
staff member whose entire job was to
stay up to date and then they would try
to let's say get them up to speed maybe
like a half hour a day or something uh
but even then they're not going to be
fully up to date uh because of the
difficulty of doing that and then how do
you actually legislate this kind of
stuff like there's so many unknowns and
the unknowns are constantly shifting and
so yeah we're just in this situation
where I'm just thinking oh my gosh like
we so desperately need Ubi to be in
place already just to handle all these
changes and just people have no idea and
they're they're not gonna get it until
like even when things are going so
quickly and you know it's even more
important than I don't know when they're
actually going to figure this out
um but I definitely have no hope in them
doing this before like people have a lot
of issues you know there's going to be
you know I I think maybe something like
we saw before like during the pandemic
you know like uh just kind of this
feeling of Anarchy as as people
um you know get really upset and and go
out in the streets and stuff like
I don't know I I don't I'm an optimist
at heart but uh I I just think that like
I said when like you mentioned earlier
it's too late and uh the question is
what can we possibly do now
um to to do this as as quickly as
possible and to do everything else we
need to do about AI
indeed my friend so I'm on the the same
wavelength I will say that um according
to uh my wife who's an excellent
Authority on these things she said that
hey if someone were to run around
um championing Ubi on the presidential
trials she was like they would do really
well because at this point there's so
many Americans who are like oh we
actually could do that you know like I
quite liked it
I mean my wife has very good instincts
like I haven't seen any of the latest
numbers to that effect
um but I do think that there is a lot of
pessimism a lot of confusion around the
inflation uh phenomenon I also think
um this economy is likely to tip into
recession sometime this next
the number of months and and so in many
ways like I'm starting to project
forward being like okay well you know
after things uh head south like there
still will be a rebuild of some kind
um you know one thing I'm optimistic
about with the Ford party is like people
are going to be like well uh you know
it's time for something new like what
the heck do I do and you know if you're
busy building something new then people
might be attracted to it
um I also have a belief that there's
going to be a surge in interest in the
forward party as soon as people realize
that their choices might be Joe Biden
and Donald Trump again
they'll be like wait a minute this
doesn't seem very very functional uh
very smart I'm not not that excited
about that it's like wait what was Yang
doing anything Yang was trying to to do
something that maybe makes this
um yeah less carved in stone
um so I I'm so I'm with you on being
pessimistic you know I'm with you one
I'd like I consider myself an optimistic
fellow and I can't do fellow I mean I
you know like what you've done holy
yeah yeah I mean what you've done is
like epic I mean you were like hey I
want to write about Ubi maybe I should
get myself a Ubi hey guys you want to
get me a Ubi so I can write about Ubi
it's like oh hey Ubi is awesome I'm like
a living walking example I mean that's a
very can-do positive uh Spirit uh you
know at the same time uh you know it's
like like uh I I'm also seeing the same
things you're seeing and being like wow
this system doesn't really care this is
really care so much about whatever the
heck is happening to yeah everything
gets transformed into partisan talking
points and you know I'm not looking
forward to AI being transformed into a
partisan matter either like fortunately
right now it's not so it's really
interesting that there's at least one
thing that people don't know what side
to be on right now and what that site is
and how to talk about it because you
know the politicians again they're so
far behind when it comes to AI that they
don't even know how to talk about it in
terms of partisanship but that's coming
and you know I I really uh I'm not
excited about when that's when that
comes and and how that plays out
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
having a good mattress has always struck
me as one of the best investments you
can make because you spend a lot of time
on that mattress and having a healthy
night's sleep gives you energy for the
day keeps you healthy makes you capable
of doing all the things you want to do
why would you sleep on a mattress that's
made for someone other than you
especially in 2023 with Helix sleep you
can take a personalized quiz get one of
their 14 unique mattresses sent right to
your door have a hundred night trial and
a 10 plus year warranty yeah they have
that much confidence in their products
in part because they're manufactured
right here in the USA and it's the
number one mattress picked by GQ in
Wired Magazine Helix is offering 20 off
all mattress orders and two free pillows
for our listeners go to helixsleep.com
yang this is their best offer yet and it
won't last long with Helix better sleep
Starts Now
[Music]
if someone wants to follow you and
support you on your Explorations how can
they best do so and what do you what do
you feel your time doing aside from
boning up on all things Ai and then
being pushed out of date like days later
yeah I always I recommend that people
follow me on on Twitter that's my my
main uh location and I have a pin thread
there of evidence that I always
recommend people check out uh you know
my my site scottsans.com I got a Ubi FAQ
there to help people learn about basic
income and yeah my patreon patreon.com
scottsanton's uh people can help with
that but the thing that
that uh one of the things I've been
working on
um lately is uh I think this is
important this goes into what we're just
talking about as far as
um you know this what do we do and if
government isn't isn't doing what it
needs to do I feel that we just need to
get Ubi going so I think uh co-mingle is
a is a platform that I think is is uh
potentially key to this so I I've been
focusing more on hopefully trying to get
that off the ground uh Cole mingle is a
is a platform where essentially people
would sign up and self-impose a seven
percent uh flat tax on themselves and
then that would result in a in a full
Ubi that's equal for every participant
and so I think that that's a you know a
real demonstration of uh you know people
being uh you know net recipients and net
payers and
um you know because people go oh well
you know if they hear about basic income
why does Bill Gates get a basic income
too
without understanding that well Bill
Gates is going to be paying a lot more
into Ubi than he is getting out of it
it's just like this really this really
uh great way of of instead of means
testing and phasing out just naturally
uh through the tax system through just
the the math of it all having it it's
such that you know the those who receive
the most have the lowest incomes and
those who
um who who pay in the most you know or
your net or net payers and not net
recipients and um like I like I want
that kind of tool like I want to be able
to actually put my money where my mouth
is and say I want to donate you know a a
net impact of say whatever it is 200 a
month or something that would go to
hopefully tens of thousands or hundreds
of thousands of people in small
increments across everybody and that
tool doesn't really exist yet and so
um it's in it can exist and it's in you
know Alpha stage right now it's not just
vaporware but I think that tools like
that like tools that actually just go
okay technology is here
we need to do something about it and
let's just use technology let's just try
to actually get these things going and
hopefully if you can get some kind of
small basic income to people some kind
of increased economic
Economic Security to people then that
will Empower them and enable them
hopefully toned down a little bit of the
insecurity and stress that's leading to
these other issues and hopefully you
know open people's minds and and open
the you know the door to legislation by
people actually understanding it and
being more empowered by it so that's
even what I'm thinking that we need to
do at this point is just like figure out
ways of directly doing this in order to
spark what needs to be done at a larger
level I love it Scott we can't wait
around uh for government to get its act
together I'll just try and take shots on
goal and solve problems ourselves uh it
actually reminds me of a meeting I had
this week with this incredible
entrepreneur who's working on a date of
Rights
uh plan and startup that I think could
actually work in the real world where
it's like no one's waiting around uh you
know if you said hey like what what do I
think the prospects are of uh the
government making it so that we have uh
agency over our own data and maybe even
get paid I'd be like you know in the U.S
like you know pretty pretty slim but
this guy is like oh I I've got a plan to
make it happen and I heard his plan I
was like that plan's really good like so
it's it's similar to what you're saying
it's like look you know maybe there are
solutions that can be built uh
independent of policy because yes you
know I mean like uh that that's what we
should be doing and these Solutions need
to help illustrate the arguments to like
really make them real for people so even
uh like when it comes to an AI dividend
utilizing the data uh like it's
interesting to see this kind of
conversation unfold the way it's been
where like I've been making the argument
that uh especially recently that hey
when it comes to large language models
you know basically the internet trained
all these things and that was me even
like you can ask gpt4 about me and and
it'll know me and based on my writing
and I can actually you know write like
me based on my writing because it's been
trained on my work and so like I'm happy
about that like I'm glad that I actually
had a bunch of stuff out there you're
glad there's a smidgen of Scots right
there's a little slice of me you know
there's a bigger slice there is the most
of us Scott because you've been putting
a lot of stuff out there this thing is
one billion Scott and one trillion the
rest of us and so yeah from from that
perspective like I'm happy that like my
my voice my work is part of this and and
it can but shouldn't you get one
billionth of the of the right but and
it's just saying that that all of us
contributed to this all of us through
all of our writing and and texts and and
tweets and everything that we've done
has helped make this possible and we
should we should tweets made this
possible Right all of our ridiculous
tweets helps train AI to like learn you
know how to predict the next word you
know based on everything that we've done
so it's been interesting that this is
just like recently just in the last like
let's say week or so you've seen like a
lot of companies
um starting to like even clamp down on
their API usage and saying you know I
don't we don't want
um these large models to actually be
using our data anymore you should pay us
kind of thing so there's like these
walls coming up
and so you know on the one hand you can
think well okay
um
put up those walls and and make sure
that your users you know get the money
for it but we all know that's not going
to happen
like these walls if they do that they're
just going to make sure that the company
itself gets the money it's going to help
profits it's going to help shareholders
it's not going to go down to the users
users still don't get anything and I
think that it's important to communicate
Ubi as an AI dividend you know in this
where we are now like I I think part of
the barrier to Ubi is people thinking
you know oh like people are going to be
left with nothing uh except for this
like poverty floor level you know basic
income and that's all that they'll get
and you know speaking of it as a
dividend as you did in your campaign you
know gets people to see that you know
people think of a dividend as the better
the company does the better I do and so
you know if you have a like a true
dividend let's say it's tied to GDP per
capita as productivity increases as AI
is able to become more more capable than
the floor Rises and that floor can be
seen as something that people you know
deserve that it's earned it's an earned
dividend it's not welfare it's not
something that somehow limits them it's
something that is supplementary to
everything else that they do and is
enabling everything that they do and
continues to increase as the the nation
improves it's a dividend on freedom my
friend
foreign
I am pumped to announce that I have a
novel coming out on September 12th the
last election it's a political thriller
co-written with my friend Stephen Marsh
who wrote the book the next civil war if
you listen to this podcast Steven's been
a repeat guest even and I became friends
and thought we should collaborate on a
way to scare the out of people but
also entertain them with a story of what
could happen in this upcoming election
or the election thereafter do check it
out at andrewyang.com books and there's
a special discount code last election
that you can use for 30 off at the
Publisher's website I'll be talking more
about this book but I'm so pumped to get
this out into the world last election
coming your way
one one personal question I have for you
is you've been living in DC for a number
of months now how is it like what's the
jam I have never lived in DC uh and like
do you hang out at these events at night
and then people are like I do this I do
this and you're like I'm like you know
like uh the walking uh example of
universal basic income you know it's
like what what what's your social life
like what's the vibe like
um is it great is it terrible is it
somewhere in between you know I I really
wouldn't say that that my experiences is
all that different uh because again I
I'm very much a remote worker you know
from my perspective it like I I really I
moved here because I I feel that we're
entering kind of like the end game part
of Ubi where you know at some point
hopefully in the next like five years or
something that will actually get
something passed that looks like a Ubi
and I think that that Windows definitely
has the potential to open and uh you
know after the next election okay they
were going to have you know first of all
who knows what how AI is going to
advance between now and November 2024.
yeah
right like for all we know let's say GPT
six or seven comes out it was like the
October surprise
and what does that mean uh for even that
election and then so people are going to
be a lot more interested in AI in in
Economic Security you know programs like
Ubi like the child allowance
um trying to figure out you know what do
we do and then also during that time
you've got um
the Trump tax credits expiring and so
you're gonna have to do stuff that
involves uh the tax code and
um and and that combination of a need to
actually
reform the tax code in another new big
way combined with
um hopefully calls for responses to Ai
and hopefully that being Ubi then a
window can potentially exist
and I I just want to be here for it to
to do what I can
um when the when the opportunities arise
well you're doing it uh everything
possible every single day my friend uh
uh glad to be on this journey alongside
you and hopefully we will have that
celebratory signing uh in in DC upcoming
the uh stepping stone I can see that's
within grasp
um uh really maybe even before 2024
um is this enhanced child tax credit
Revival uh and when people uh ask me
about Ubi and the data I say hey what if
I were to tell you that we gave like 93
billion dollars to a few million
families around the US and their mental
health improved in their educational
outcomes improved and we just did this
literally like you know like you know
you
it's like you know I mean to your point
it's like we have plenty of data that
this would be tremendous and most people
don't think of that child tax credit as
Ubi but
um you and I both know it's very much an
enormous anti-poverty measure uh and I I
think that can be
something we should be aiming towards
because the people love it economists
love it the data love it a lot of
legislators I talk to love it as well
including some folks who are you know
not uh
um ideologically like what you know
where you'd expect yeah I mean it's
families were on average receiving what
428 dollars a month
and you know that was that was a floor
for them and you know it was just
there's so many multiple Papers written
about this it went to 90 of kids in the
U.S like
the effects were just amazing to see and
then even like when they canceled it or
when it expired and didn't restore it
um it was just you know we actually
watched the parental employment rate go
down so here we are like the
conversation is oh oh we can't give
money to people or else we'll stop
working and it's like well that's not
what we saw and then you know you've got
people going oh well you know that's
only because it lasted for six months
but if it lasted for longer than that
then that's not the case and it's like
well the same thing is in Canada and
they've had it for years and it's great
up there so like you know the evidence
is is so strong for people who actually
look at it and even base their decisions
on evidence but I feel the the anecdotes
you know that's you've got your your
Welfare Queen mythology you've got your
oh I know one person who did this or
only caring about one person like oh if
only one per person uses their basic
income you know to start drinking or
doing drugs then that's bad it's like
well but the evidence shows that overall
drug and alcohol use goes down so isn't
that what we want like
um so we've got like this kind of
um this this anecdotal evidence problem
and so I think a key to that is being
able to really richly and powerfully
tell these stories so like another
project I'm excited about uh to getting
off the ground is uh bootstraps and so
this was a two and a half year basic
income program that was filmed
over that time so there's like a
thousand hours of footage of of 21
people living with a basic income both
before and during the pandemic and the
demographics are just very diverse
amount of people including a southern
conservative Trump supporter and to be
able to like see these stories and see
how it impacted them I think it's just
really powerful and we need to get those
kinds of stories out there for people to
connect with
and I think that's one of the things
that that's missing are these really
possible can people see that bootstraps
film now
it's uh in post uh production right now
very exciting red carpet
so hopefully it'll end up being on like
you know your Netflix or HBO or or
something I like it but I think that's
the kind of thing that people need to
see like when made came out of Netflix
that was a great show and I think people
um kind of gained a better understanding
of you know what it's like for a a
single mother uh fleeing uh household
you know domestic abuse uh and even
trying to get a job and going through
the welfare system and then like jumping
through those bureaucratic hoops and
being yeah like all that stuff it was it
was great we need stories like that that
people can connect to yeah sometimes
um art can move the culture in a
positive direction uh you know I'm
taking a shot or two in that direction
I've got this political thriller coming
out in September uh that's why I'm
painting a picture about I got to send
you the manuscript bro
um it's already been to paint a picture
about what our you know what our last
election could look like I guess
unfortunately that's like not a very
distant future anymore as a possibility
uh well Scott uh so thrilled to to have
uh this opportunity to pick your brain a
little bit more uh learn a lot from you
every single time if we get to Ubi
you're going to be one of the big
reasons why
um and I say that as a public figure
that is commonly associated with Ubi but
I'm also the first to say it's like look
guys like Ubi is definitely not my idea
I mean it was like MLK Thomas Paine and
I don't always say Scott sandens because
you know that it's like doesn't hit that
historical figure
but people in the know know it's got
sentence hope you and Katie are great
down in DC and that I get to see you
soon thanks and one other thing too I
wanted uh to mention to you oh Titus
wants to show up uh oh God I just turned
six yesterday
and I guess one other thing too before I
go
is uh I don't know if you noticed uh the
press release that the the Gerald fun
free managers put out yesterday that was
our response to the um open letter uh
that you signed for the pause in Ai and
that was uh our response to saying you
know as part of any pause that Ubi needs
to be part of this conversation like
this is just such an important element
of this
um you know we should focus on on
responsible AI development and you know
everything that goes along with the
other dangers but we absolutely have to
keep an eye on the ball as far as the
labor market transformation and what's
going to happen to people's Economic
Security and that Ubi is just a
foundational element for for everything
they're going to see I love it I
certainly hope that uh we can advance
Ubi uh as really the only logical
response to AI becoming smarter and more
powerful uh every single day oh and uh
another thing I think that you would
enjoy Joy too is I don't know if you you
noticed uh saw this yet but it's a a
Japanese translation of my book uh that
I'm pretty excited about congratulations
yeah International author now multiple
languages I thought it was so cool and
you know there's original illustrations
for it and and it just looks really neat
so I I hope that it does well in Japan
and uh you know if other countries are
out there listening uh South Korea
looking at you uh yeah it sounds very
Nordic Nations
but for anyone go to scottsantons.com
s-a-n-t-e-n-s for all of Scott's
writings and wisdom and by his book
scottsantons.com thanks yeah and uh got
a really exciting project coming up
can't talk about that one yet but just
so people know that there is something
I'm cooking up that I'm hoping to uh be
able to announce in the next couple
months well thanks so much for coming on
see you soon my friend Scott santins at
scottsantons.com
thanks good to see you again Andrew